Salut les mentalos !
Dans la
vidéo numéro 244 avec Romain de la chaîne
TechNews&Tests j'avais fait un
battle contre Akinator.
Ça m'a donné l'idée de la vidéo du jour
250/366 : comment gagner à tous
les coups au "qui est-ce" ? Il y a vraiment une astuce
pour gagner au "qui est-ce", puisque
la stratégie du "qui est-ce" ne diffère pas trop de
ce que j'ai fait avec Romain
puisqu'on a tous un stock d'informations et
on va pouvoir faire un tunnel pour trouver
le plus rapidement et le plus facilement
possible l'information en question parmi
tout ce choix. Un espèce de stock-reading
mélangé à l'effet tunnel dans
la recherche d'infos. L'idéal serait
donc de faire une dichotomie à chaque coup
Une dichotomie, qu'est-ce que la dichotomie ?
C'est juste une division en deux parties.
Au "qui est-ce" classique à la base il y a 24
possibilité donc faudrait qu'on passe
à 12 et puis ensuite à 6 et puis
ensuite à 3 et puis ensuite à 2
et puis ensuite à 1 et là
Bam ! On gagnerait en cinq coups mais
c'est impossible parce que déjà
il n'y a rien qui permette au "qui est-ce" de
passer de 24 à 12 c'est à dire que le
créateur du "qui est-ce",on s'est dit
"Oh, il a une idée sympa
mais ce n'était pas si compliqué que ça à mettre en place."
Il a vraiment pensé à tout ça pour
qu'on ne puisse pas à la première
question éliminer la moitié du
jeu. Ils sont malins Theo et Ora
parce qu'ils sont deux à avoir créé le jeu du "qui est-ce". Ce sont Theo
et Ora Coster. Mais en étudiant la question j'ai compris qu'on pouvait
gagner en six coups puisque de toute
manière on pourrait pas résoudre le
problème du premier coup, de la première
dichotomie, on ne peut pas le faire,
on peut quand même gagner en 6 coups.
Je vais vous expliquer comment, tout en
sachant que gagner en 6 coups
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir un facteur
chance en face l'autre peut trouver
par exemple en disant "Bah je pense que t'as machin." Il a une chance sur 24 de réussir en faisant comme ça
mais dans le long terme vous serez
toujours
plus souvent gagnants
que perdant en utilisant cette technique-là.
On va utiliser des éléments qui
sont très peu utilisés dans les
questions du "qui est-ce". On pense toujours à
homme/femme ce genre de choses mais
c'est pas forcément les meilleures
questions à poser. Ma première question
au "qui est-ce" c'est
est-ce que la personne que tu as choisie a
des rides ?
Si c'est oui alors n'y a plus que 8
solutions différentes.
Si c'est non il n'y a plus que 16 solutions
différentes et si la réponse est oui
vous avez gagné en trois coups maximum.
Donc je vous fais le chemin comme ça en
passant
par le côté rides oui. Est-ce que
là personne a des rides ? Oui. Ensuite
est-ce qu'elle est chauve ? Si c'est oui,
est-ce qu'elle a des lunettes ? Et vous avez la réponse. L'autre possibilité avec des rides ? oui,
c'est est-ce qu'elle a des rides ? oui. Est-ce qu'elle est chauve ?
non. Dans ces cas-là est-ce que la
personne est brun ou brune ? et là
vous avez la réponse.
Si la réponse pour les rides est non, alors vous
demandez si la personne a des fossettes,
des jolies fossettes. Si la réponse est oui
alors vous demandez à la personne si elle a un
chapeau et là vous avez quasiment
terminé et si la réponse est non vous
demandez si c'est une fille et là c'est
quasiment terminé surtout si c'est oui,
si c'est une fille sinon il y aura sûrement
une question en plus. A vous d'adapter, là
il reste quasiment plus grand chose devant vous. J'ai pris aujourd'hui exemple du
"qui est-ce", mais c'est applicable à plein de
choses, c'est applicable même à des choix qui
n'ont rien à voir c'est même
applicable à akinator, c'est applicable
à des nombres et des chiffres, vous pouvez le faire sur rien. Juste dans ces cas-là si vous le
faites sur un objet, n'importe quel objet
alors pensez toujours à réfléchir
à des choses qui vont vraiment
concrètement vous aider et les réponses
qui vont vous resservir, même peut-être
plus tard, si c'est un objet,
au lieu de demander si c'est gros ou petit,
demandez concrètement est-ce que ça
tient dans la main, est ce que c'est plus gros qu'un ballon de foot, cherchez
son utilisation et surtout... tricher
*rires*
Il a dit de tricher ? Oui j'ai dis de
tricher, mais de tricher intelligemment.
C'est à dire pas tricher pour tricher,
utilisez toutes les réactions non verbales de la personne. Vous avez la personne qui est en
face de vous donc vous pouvez utiliser
toutes ses réactions, ses sourires, son
visage... Moi il y a quelque chose que
j'aime bien faire, c'est faire des
affirmations c'est à dire, je n'utilise pas une question, je donne une affirmation,
et je regarde juste la réaction sur le visage, si elle est plutôt positive ou
négative et donc j'ai une réponse non verbale et là je pose
directement une question.
C'est pas très fair-play comme truc mais c'est légal, ça rentre dans les règles.
Si ça vous tente je peux faire aussi d'autres astuces sur
d'autres jeux de société comme j'en
avais déjà fait d'ailleurs par le
passé, proposez-moi dans les
commentaires des jeux auxquels je
pourrais parler, évidemment il va y avoir le poker, faut que j'en reparle. J'en avais
déjà parlé une ou deux fois du poker, du blackjack.
Je vais revenir aussi un petit peu sur ce
genre de jeu, mais proposez-moi des jeux
de société classiques avec grand
plaisir. Merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo. Si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas
à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit
et magnifique pouce en l'air ! Ça faisait que je ne vous l'avait pas fait comme ça, celui-là.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir et
rendez-vous de demain à 17 heures
Ciao !